Y
or not
to
and such
ah
these armed men arrived
threatening us and knocking down doors of the
homes and getting wanting
so that we give them to nothing more than
phones for everything we had
because of that day everyone started to
take out their little things because yes I cried
also up to screaming because some
running like this on the road or as
we came along the road the children with
his little backpack just running down
because they said they were going to go back to
kill us
ah
i
good
They even told him that the ghost town
because there were no people
we have spoken against nobody we want
tranquility peace to continue living the
happening of loss because then there is no
another we indicate it to relapse everything
through pasadena